il y a un an le film américain le
revenant filmé dans la nature sauvage de
l'ouest canadien mettait en vedette les
trappeurs canadien un film qui a volé la
vedette aux oscars ce long métrage
mettait donc en lumière la force
psychologique des trappeurs du 19e
siècle qui ne pouvaient souvent compter
que ce re mêmes pour survivre dans des
conditions extrêmes l'hiver rappeur nord
ontarien conrad morin compare les
conditions de la trappe à l'époque à
celle d'aujourd'hui que j'étais j'ai lu
tout neuf dans leur groupe
l'équipe - donc il devrait avoir quatre
cinq rapports ou une dizaine de rapports
ou 12 frappeurs qui souhaite rappeler le
même terrain donc c'était vraiment un
jour sur les populations
c'était une compétition féroce quand on
frappe on perd on est seul alboury aux
fonctions en train avec des équipements
de machinerie
donc si le problème est nue où il arrive
quelque chose j'ai tâché de
l'actionnaire arrive à tout le monde si
l'on troqué les traditionnels requête ou
chevaux pour la motoneige leur passion
demeure exigeante les champs rudi est
l'un d'entre eux posté à manama
c'est une des espèces les plus présentes
on peut retrouver le ici en région sur
la côte-nord le placard ça oscille à
l'automne disons-le à l'autre sont
présentes dans la déco attend à
respecter comme souhaité un piégeage on
a quand même une limite le minimum de 5
à prendre avec 15 au total
mais absolument un trappeur com - le
palais cherche jusqu'à soixante et dix
82 quoi même jusqu'à fin byte le
facilement le parfait la dass des
animaux en fonction
bon an mal an uniquement au québec
il se vend entre 6500 et 7000 permis de
piégeage selon marc andré racines
promoteur de la trappe au nord du québec
dans une région sauvage appelée wayne
randa et où chaque hiver on organise un
salon de la trace de dégâts ce temps que
j'ai pogné que je fais des mitaines avec
ce 4 gâteau saad al saad
thématique l'outillage et là le 25
octobre arrive tout le monde at a adapté
ses tresses farces et attrapes thierry
en manque de jawdat retraité depuis 14
ans + trappe depuis 30 ans alors là vous
allez avoir l'occasion de voir les
footeux tanné de chacun au niveau de la
région et voir aussi quels traitements
qu'on leur donne pour enfin des peaux
tannées marcel lavoie et secrétaire de
l'association des trappeurs de rouyn
noranda a lieu une dépression à cause de
son soutien des dents par toro de la
mauvaise image trappage c'est devenu mon
est payant et on aimait tant soucieux de
ne pas faire de cruauté de parapet d'un
animal avec cruauté les biens sont
standardisés sont étudiées alors là on
lui un espèce de creux de vague mais
maintenant nous voir et on voit arriver
à nouveau une nouvelle génération qui
suivent un cours une formation pour
devenir à part ça prend deux formations
professionnelles ce deux jours pour être
justement et applique les techniques de
code de code d'éthique d'être à pas
depuis quand même plusieurs années puis
1998 je crois on est obligé de suivre un
cours
si vous voulez vous adonner au piégeage
bien gingras est journaliste au
quotidien m'ont rien à la prince depuis
près de 35 ans il se spécialise dans les
sciences naturelles et donc il y en a
une trentaine de milles personnes qui
ont suivi ce cours là les les trappeurs
qui font des revenus importants en même
temps de quelques dizaines de milliers
de dollars
les trappes a qui font des revenus
importants passe près de carrément tout
leur temps le temps de la saison donc on
parle de l'automne tard jusqu'au
printemps tardif
ils vont passer tout leur temps à
consacrer leur activité s'est attrapé
donc c'est un travail presque 20 84 ça
c'est la minorité pour la plupart d'être
à part c'est avant tout un loisir qui va
rapporter quelque souk sutout finance en
partie le late le trappage au québec où
la trappe peut rapporter rapporte à peu
près bon an mal an après 7 millions de
dollars c'est pas une fortune
c'est pas vraiment beaucoup et de ce
nombre là il y en a un petit nombre
effectivement qu'ils vont en faire
beaucoup plus que d'autres parce qu'il
met l'énergie sur le court à forest l'a
suggéré prix plus d'affaires c'est
pourquoi met-on à prendre
à l'école c'est facile à prendre
du haut de ses 14 ans gabriel bélanger
bien jean compagne de son père michel
bélanger au québec la martre le castor
et bien d'autres espèces à fourrure au
nord de port cartier sur la côte nord
gabriel fait partie donc de cette rare
relève à faire du piégeage
ça laisse place à l'imagination peut des
fois dans la peau de l'animal fait qui
se promène en forêt est pétri cherche
quelque chose à manger souvent le décès
des choses peut mener aux mêmes ça a
marché à new richmond dans le nord du
québec
le chasseur cueilleur et rappeur bernard
dubé prépare également les pots pour la
vente de fourrure aujourd'hui je vais
t'emmener dans mon atelier où je prépare
mes pots et ouvre entrepose dépôt son
pote terminé d'après est aidé en voilà
[Musique]
cela vient venue d'alain du coureur gros
j'ai fait un peu de feu d'un poids elle
pour porte très froid durant la période
que tu veux ma 6t pour la prêter de la
fourrure
ce matin mon mât g13 bellemare a apprêté
à dépiauter à dégraisser et à placer sur
les fûts j'ai un castor à dépiauter
dégraisser et moulay ça fait que on va
en avoir pour un petite partie de
l'avant-midi sommes installés ici pour
des piloter dépiauter c'est enlever la
peau d'un animal dont avec un couteau
pointu vient fin d'ici là à l'arrière
des pins pour cette affaire jusqu au
bout de l'eau la patte du côté opposé
un reportage de radio canada
international